do you believe in paying for your first
date if I ask them out then I think I
should what's your ideal first date
biking to Manhattan and just being in
the crowd like being in the commotion
right I think that's pretty cute yeah
biking together the lifestyle that he
described to me I just don't think he
fit very well with mine do you believe
in opinionated a woman yeah I think like
everyone's sort of entitled to their
opinions and like cherished for them I
would love for us to be on the same page
about opinions and I would prefer
somebody with a strong opinion even if
it's different from mine than somebody
who doesn't really know what to believe
in if you don't really have set opinions
about what you want what you believe in
I feel like that makes a person boring
you don't want to get into a
relationship and just like walk all over
the person or just control everything